um yeah there were things also in the
original script I'd be like I don't
think it would I I that would I'd find a
bit hard to say or do you mind if I give
a stab at this or and he was completely
cool with that and think
um you know because he does know me so
well and knows how I perform and and
knows what he wanted from me as a
performer it meant that I could also
then ask the same of him
um and that was an amazing experience to
have it was very free for everybody else
there not just me you know he wrote the
film for me but
um every character had the every actor
and every character had the ability to
show up on the day they were working and
mean something